Uh-huh.
Boo.
Good afternoon, Karen.
Hello, how are you?
I'm doing good, how about you?
Good, good.
So I think we were meeting first time.
Excuse me?
We're meeting first time, right?
Yes.
Anyone else going to be joined?
I honestly don't know.
Okay, I think before we start, I probably can give you my introduction. So, earlier Mohit used to take care of the APM IT engineer.
So they're in a different location, but now what we have planned, the rest of two people that we have and the third one that we recently hired, they are in Noida location. Some operating from Noida. So that is the main reason to do this whole transition. So that way all the engineer are at the same place. I can take care of them personally.
Okay.
Currently we have like a one people here in Noida, two are in Chandigarh. So kind of make it a bigger team and support them physically on the location.
I think, and that was the reason of the transition and about myself. So I work as a technical lead here in ITBD by design. It's almost 8 year since I'm working. So I'm physically handling the team, supporting them, taking care of everything if they need any support on a physical, provide them the facilities, help them on a technical side.
Any immediate support they needed, so I'm taking care of that also in a self-service delivery point of view.
Okay.
Let me see if anyone else can do join.
So I don't think anyone else from ITBD designs are going to be joined.
Jim won't be joining, and I'm not sure about Alex.
Okay, yeah, then we'll give a few minutes to.
Alex usually runs late though, so...
Yeah.
Yeah, no, we'll give a few minutes to be that way they can join, then we can start.
OK.
So, do you work into the evening as well, then?
No, just the regular 8 to 5 Eastern.
Okay.
But in the different shift, we have the tech lead who are available for support, the people who are working on the off hours and any other shift.
So that we can just kind of cover 24 by 7.
I said, that's Anamish. She's going to be working in the evening hours, right, overnight?
Yeah.
Boo.
Doesn't look like anyone else is joining us.
Yeah, Shashank probably, so just, you know, this is the first call that we have, right? You probably already had previous call, but Mohit, right? So this is just the purpose of discussing the performance, checking everything, how is everything going? So you are the one who is going to take care of everything from...
Any anything from the APM side or?
Actually, that's usually Alex, but he asked Jim and I to come in on this meeting because he was so swamped. And I know Jim was doing the signing of tickets and everything, but now Shivani's doing that. And I mean, like I just kind of get involved when I see a ticket.
Yeah.
That's been open for a long time, and I kind of remind them about the ticket, but I don't really have...
I don't know how well they're doing with the tickets, basically.
Yeah.
Okay, yeah. So what do we recommend? Maybe any other time that we schedule the call and...
We can schedule another call. Yeah, I just, I only work Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, 8 to 5.
Tuesday.
So, I'll be here tomorrow, but I won't be here Friday or Monday.
So maybe tomorrow, same time if that worked for you. Maybe Alex will be there too. Yeah, so I'll send you the invite, right? Because I have you action tracker item that we need to discuss, right? And so I'll send you the invite for tomorrow, the same time.
Sure.
Okay.
Yeah, thank you. We'll see you tomorrow then. Take care. Pleasure to meet you. Bye.
Okay, bye. Nice meeting you.
Bye.